certaines personnes qui trafiquaient
dans le Stup se sont aperçus que
peut-être dans le foot c'était un peu
moins dangereux parce que peut-être il y
avait pas encore énormément de
concurrence pour l'instant
salut je m'appelle Daniel riollot je
suis journaliste RMC éditorialiste je
bosse également pour BFM parfois j'ai
commencé dans différents médias jusqu'à
arriver au début il y avait un faux
sport TPS enfin il y avait pas mal de
médias jusqu'à arriver à RMC en 2007
2006 qu'est-ce que je raconte 2007 2006
avril 2006 et puis voilà ça fait
maintenant 17 ans l'After Foot
évidemment s'installer dans la durée
quand on a cette chance et bah ça permet
de créer quelque chose de fort ou une
super belle aventure avec toute une
bande de potes maintenant parce que ça
fait certes Gilbert et moi au départ
mais au fil du temps on a construit
quelque chose de d'assez fort avec plein
plein de de personnes qui nous
accompagnent depuis le début et surtout
des bosses qui nous soutiennent qui nous
aiment et qu'on aime c'est vraiment une
histoire fantastique moi je disais
beaucoup de magazines de foot mais pas
que d'ailleurs parce que je pense qu'à
un moment je voulais être journaliste
tout court le foot c'était un peu la
cerise sur le gâteau parce que si déjà
tu veux faire ce que tu veux mais en
plus dans le ce que tu veux il y a un
bout de ta passion voilà c'est c'est
bingo quoi et j'ai vu cette chance
vraiment parce que j'estime que c'est
une chance pourquoi le foot bah parce
que j'adore ça depuis que je suis petit
parce que c'est une culture chez nous
parce que c'est quelque chose que je
suis depuis que je suis enfant et voilà
c'est une passion c'est quelque chose de
profondément ancré en moi comme un
moment
comme le tennis qui est une autre de mes
passions parfois on me demande et tu
adores le foot c'est ta passion mais tu
parles souvent de ce qui va pas alors
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai que
je parle souvent de ce qui va pas
peut-être parce que en fait j'aime
tellement ça que je dois l'idéaliser et
que j'aimerais en extraire ce qui va pas
c'est évidemment fondamentalement
impossible donc je me résous à parler de
de ce qui ne va pas de de ce qui va
aussi parce qu'au final si on devait
faire réellement le bilan ça doit être
du 55 ans parler de véritables émotions
des choses qui nous plaisent dans
l'émission et effectivement des choses
qui vont pas et
se fait souvent par le biais de livres
comme le dernier donc Kao Football Club
où j'évoque pas mal d'affaires qu'on
secouait le football français donc avec
mon coeur Abdelkrim Brahim que
j'embrasse c'est pas un mal qui frappe
uniquement le foot parce que il y a
plein de bouquins qui parlent des
affaires dans le monde politique au
financier dans plein de domaines donc
nous notre matière c'est le foot donc le
le mal c'est des rivalités qu'elle soit
sportive ou économique nous ce qu'on a
voulu raconter si on devait faire un
dessin ce serait que le foot va serait
comme un gros gâteau et on a noté ces
dernières années de plus en plus de de
gens de vautours qui tournent autour de
ce gros gâteau et qui veulent tous
grignoter une part prendre une part de
plus en plus importante ce sont tous ces
joueurs de foot qui souffrent
d'entourage de plus en plus vorace et
qui veulent prendre une fameuse part de
de ce gâteau mais le mal il est pas
uniquement autour des joueurs de foot il
est également puisqu'on raconte les
affaires qu'on touchait la Fédération
française de football c'est ce mal qui
peut toucher parfois ce qui atteignent
une sorte de sommet de succès et c'est
cette fédération française de foot qui
après la victoire de l'équipe de France
à la Coupe du Monde 2018 a complètement
vrillé en excès de tout genre et toutes
ces affaires qui ont été révélées
notamment par l'audit qui a été mené par
le ministère des sports où on a noté
effectivement de harcèlement moral
harcèlement sexuel il y a des gens dans
l'univers du foot qui se sont dits en
tout cas quand on a rencontré des gens
proches du milieu et également des
enquêteurs qui de plus en plus mettent
là on est dans les affaires du football
on a pu entendre des phrases assez
étonnantes comme quoi certaines
personnes qui trafiquaient dans le Stup
ce sont aperçus que peut-être dans le
foot c'était un peu moins dangereux
parce que peut-être il y avait pas
encore énormément de concurrence pour
l'instant mais oui que le monde du
banditisme ou grand banditisme
s'approche du foot après attention on
n'est pas dans la a découverte le bon
grand banditisme il s'est intéressé à
Marseille déjà il était là dans les
années 80-90 la mafia corso marseillaise
il y a des livres qui ont été écrits
là-dessus bien avant le nôtre nous
peut-être qu'on s'intéresse désormais à
la nouvelle forme que ça a pris
notamment dans certains quartiers où
autour de joueurs qui viennent de
quartier d'un des amis peut-être un
petit peu trop encombrants un peu à
l'image de ce qui peut se passer dans le
milieu du rap pour l'instant on peut pas
dire que la fédé
se rendent bien compte de ce qui se
passe il y a eu pas mal d'affaires
d'exercices illégal de la profession
d'agent qui ont pas profondément touché
la fédé qui s'est dit bon bah de toute
façon c'est pas nos affaires nous on
attribue les licences aux agents les
faux agents on les reconnaît pas après
c'est au club aussi de faire attention
si les clubs ouvrent la porte à
n'importe qui
ça peut donner lieu effectivement
ensuite des formes de chantage ou des
formes de raquettes les clubs parfois
ils veulent le joueur à tout prix parce
qu'ils se disent que ce joueur va
apporter quelque chose à l'équipe et
parfois il faut pas attention quand ils
ouvrent la porte du bureau à la personne
qui est en face d'elle face ça peut
créer pas mal d'histoires assez
embêtante pour les clubs mais c'est au
club de faire attention aussi il y a des
clubs qui font attention un club comme
l'OL qui fait très attention quand le
directeur sportif décroche le téléphone
on fait attention à qui on a au bout du
fil quand même il faut que ce soit des
gens des gens on va dire compétents et
pas des agents improvisés de dernière
minute Pogba à faire elle est
extraordinaire dans le sens où elle
touche un footballeur de renommée
international ça séquestration elle a eu
lieu en plus quasiment en marge dans
rassemblement de l'équipe de France elle
est exceptionnelle aussi parce que c'est
la première fois qu'un joueur de cette
importance
ose parler au départ des amis d'enfance
qui laissent la place à des bandits qui
avec des fusils à pompe le menaces de
devoir payer une somme très importante
pour une protection la famille est
également mêlée parce que l'un des
frères de Pogba a certainement été
instrumentalisé ou lui-même s'est dit
que son frère l'avait peut-être pas bien
traité et lui avait ensuite peut-être
parlé à des gens à qui l'auraient pas dû
parler on est dans une affaire assez
grave qui au final a envoyé deux trois
personnes en tôle qui sont sortis on
parle de ça dans le milieu du foot mais
on peut dire également la même chose des
comédiens des artistes les gens qui les
gèrent les gens qui les entourent sont
souvent très importants dans le
développement de la carrière de la
personne concernée le PSG aujourd'hui
dans le top 10 en Europe ça ne dépend
que des dirigeants plus que de Mbappé
d'être encore plus fort si un jour on se
décide à gérer ce club normalement comme
un club de foot et pas comme un club de
foot et également une agence de cinéma
et un baby-sitting amélioré pour joueur
capricieux si on devient enfin un club
normal ben Mbappé profitera du club pour
un épanouissement total et peut-être
qu'on arrêtera de se faire taper en
Ligue des champions comme des comme des
enfants au huitièmes de finale si enfin
on extrait du vestiaire tous les
problèmes qu'il annoncent club et tout
et tous ces fameuses starlettes
capricieuses peut-être que maté pourra
s'épanouir dans un collectif bien
meilleur on verra en tout cas moi je lui
conseille pas de partir en tout cas je
pense que de toute façon cette année il
va rester et je pense qu'il va donner
une peut-être une dernière chance au
club de se gérer
normalement on va voir je pense qu'il
attend impatiemment comme nous
d'ailleurs de savoir qui va être
l'entraîneur et surtout quel sera le
recrutement et après on verra bien ce
qui adviendra de la saison à venir je
pense que le club est tombé tellement
bas que c'est un peu une sorte de
dernière chance et pour le PSG et pour
Mbappé qui s'il voit que vraiment il y a
rien à faire dans ce club et jamais ça
sera géré normalement il partira l'année
prochaine par l'esprit du groupe
évidemment que qu'un joueur comme Mbappé
qui est ultra exigeant peut pas
supporter que des joueurs qui sont des
stars dans le vestiaire ne soient pas là
ne répondent pas présent ce serait la
meilleure nouvelle c'est que toutes ces
starlettes s'en aille parce que des
joueurs qui s'entraînent mal ne font
même pas 30 matchs par saison ou
participe à des soirées qui abîment leur
corps en dire plus au bout d'un moment
c'est pas c'est pas digne de sportif
professionnel à partir du moment où les
mecs font même pas 30 pattes sur la
saison comment tu veux construire un
collectif quand tu es quand tu es là une
fois sur deux on peut pas construire sur
toi un match tu es votre match n’était
pas là une période t-linge une période
tu es pas là ça casse complètement le
développement collectif d'une équipe en
fait donc n'importe quel entraîneur
pourra t'expliquer ça donc je comprends
pas que le club continue d'accepter ce
genre de situation là moi j'adore Messi
j'aime Messie avec l'Argentine j'ai même
ici avec le Barça mais ici avec le PSG
j'ai rien vu quoi ça m'a servi à rien de
le voir moi je le trouvais mieux avant
bah c'est une réussite marketing il a
fait vendre beaucoup de maillots il a
fait venir beaucoup de touristes à Paris
il a permis Marketplace de bien bien
fonctionner là le second marché des
places beaucoup de supporters se sont
enrichis également en revendant leur
place à des touristes ils voulaient
absolument voir Messi donc pour le
business ça a été bon pour tout le monde
du supporter au club après sportivement
rien quoi ça rien apporté à part deux
trois photos quelques quelques buts de
trois passes la rencontre Messi Paris
sportivement c'est un échec total mais
de toute façon j'ai jamais pensé que ça
pouvait être une réussite donc j'ai pas
été déçu il va falloir que quand on pose
mettre son nez il a très envie lui tout
le temps de se mêler du du terrain alors
que il y a pas mal d'entraîneurs qui ne
supporteront jamais ça je pense Thiago
Motta Luis Enrique Alonso c'est pas le
genre ces mecs là à accepter qu'un
directeur sportif soit là ou descendre
sur le terrain comme ça s'est passé lors
d'un PSG Lille au Parc des Princes un
entraîneur normal se retourne et dit au
directeur sportif qu'est-ce que tu fous
là casse-toi à moins qu'on pose et la
lucidité de dire ok je prends vraiment
du recul et je fais mon métier je laisse
rentrer en faire son métier auquel cas
si c'est mon choix personnel je suis
venu anti-gomota qui est un gars du club
qui est un super entraîneur qui va être
réclamé par les plus grands clubs dans
le dans les semaines à venir donc autant
le prendre chez nous puisque c'est un
parisien au moment où on se parle la
finale de l'Europa League n'a pas eu
lieu si la romain gagne je pense que ça
va donner un crédit énorme à Mourinho et
compo c'est lui il se connaîtrait très
très bien c'est le jeu le plus horrible
de la série a ça va être le jeu le plus
horrible en Ligue 1 en Coupe d'Europe on
va se faire chier quoi mais vraiment
vraiment Zidane à Marseille alors il va
falloir qu'il y ait des moyens alors
après tout il est né là-bas c'est sa
ville sa famille sera certainement
contente ça ferait une magnifique
moi je trouverais ça absolument génial
comme histoire très magnifique il a
envie il a envie d'entraîner il y a pas
beaucoup de place qui vont se libérer
prochainement pas franchement je je
trouverai ça génial quoi l'Arabie
saoudite a de l'oseille et que la
rencontre entre l'Arabie Saoudite et des
joueurs de foot qui aiment le Zaïs ça
peut se faire Cristiano Ronaldo il est
allé je sais pas si c'est beaucoup amusé
il y a même pas réussi à gagner bah
écoute si tous les mecs en fin de
carrière veulent aller là-bas et que ça
remplit les stades et que l'Arabie
Saoudite pense que grâce à ça ça va
améliorer son image ou ça va renvoyer
une belle image du pays qui le fasse si
les joueurs acceptent qu'ils y aille
parce qu'il y a pas de joueurs de 25 ans
qui iront là-bas franchement ça me
laisse totalement indifférent
honnêtement si on me demande de faire
l'after on Arabie Saoudite pour 200
millions je vais demander une journée de
réflexion parce que ça fait un peu homme
d'affaires de demander une journée de
réflexion je pense qu'au bout de 5
minutes j'aurai décidé hein je crois pas
que l'avenir du foot se déplacera là-bas
on a cru ça de la Chine à une époque le
Qatar c'était mis à recruter des
retraités mais après les clubs européens
sont historiquement trop fort pour que
pour l'instant en tout cas à moins une
énorme révolution ça bouge et que je
sais pas moi le championnat de l'arabout
ça vous dites se mettent à accueillir
des stars même à 20 ans quoi là j'ai du
mal à y croire que ça devienne l'EHPAD
du football ça c'est possible mais pas
un championnat majeur non donc est-ce
que l'Arabie Saoudite tirera profit de
faire venir des stars pour améliorer son
image honnêtement je suis pas certain
moi j'ai pas de pression j'ai des
process pas pareil pression et procès si
le procès peut déclencher une forme de
presse les process un peu chiant ouais
parce que ça ça prend beaucoup de temps
ça occupe ça bizarrement ça donne
l'impression dans l'opinion que parce
qu'on te fait un procès à tort alors que
jusqu'à preuve du contraire mais t'as
pas tort c'est juste que le mec
t'attaque il attaque souvent un peu pour
te faire taire ou pour te mettre la
pression justement mais tant que la
justice se prononce pas pour l'instant
j'en ai eu trois j'ai gagné les trois
bon là maintenant il y en a d'autres en
cours on verra bien si jamais je suis
condamné en diffamation bah ça voudra
dire que ce que j'ai dit et j'avais pas
le droit de le dire mais arrêtez il lui
a mis la pression vers un tien Jérôme tu
as mis la pression du tout il a dit
Jérôme tu devrais pas dire ça sur moi et
c'est mon Marco qui sont dans la
c'est vraiment c'est quoi d'appeler
comme ça non mais les joueurs moyens il
y en a plein qui m'ont téléphoné bon
maintenant ils le font plus ça sert à
rien mais il y en a plein qui ont tenté
de me téléphoner à une époque et alors
que ça peut faire tu discutes et puis
voilà tu discutes il dit ouais c'est
chiant que les mec souvent en plus ils
sont pas méchants quand il téléphone il
menacent pas une fois des champs m'avait
appelé franchement il avait employé un
ton qui m'avait pas plu donc je lui
avais dit excuse-moi si je comprends
bien tu es en train de me menacer ou pas
il m'a dit non pardon pardon c'est pas
ce que tu crois et tout ça d'accord ok
pardon derrière
plus jamais échanger un mot il y a eu un
climat qui est devenu totalement glacial
jusqu'au procès récent j'avais compris
comment il avait pu me passer un coup de
fil pareil quoi donc sélectionneur de
l'équipe de France c'est un peu un peu
un peu un un peu limite quoi voilà donc
il attendait que je me dégonfle à ce
moment-là mais ce coup de fil vraiment
j'ai j'ai jamais réellement compris
beaucoup de joueurs qui m'ont téléphoné
donc jamais employé ton là quoi voilà et
j'ai quand même le droit également de
penser que sa gestion de Benzema la
Coupe du Monde et sujette à caution et
que selon moi nous a caché quelque chose
ça lui a pas plu fait un procès la
justice tranchera je ne crois pas le
harceler je crois qu'on a le droit de
critiquer Macron on a le droit de
critiquer
Donald Trump homme d'affaires Didier n'a
pas le droit ok très bien on a pas le
droit j'ai effectivement la fâcheuse
tendance et manie à répondre aux
insultes bon je sais que je devrais pas
mais je comprends toujours pas que
quelqu'un puisse gratuitement comme ça
alors que il y a juste à ne pas me
follow ou ne pas m'écouter et il passe à
autre chose j'ai du mal à comprendre
comment le gars peut venir insulter ou
parler de ma femme ou d'un tel et je
comprends pas souvent le mec dit
pourquoi tu insultes parce que la
réputation c'est un Riolo il insulte sur
Twitter ah bon bah qu'un mec vient de me
dire si je l'ai insulté alors que il
l'avait pas fait avant mais alors
maintenant j'ai découvert un autre truc
c'est que les gars ils disent mais non
non c'était pas insulté alors j'ai un
doute je remonte les messages alors donc
malhonnête c'est être dire que quelqu'un
qui malhonnête c'est visiblement pas une
insulte insulter la femme donc c'est pas
une insulte parce que c'est pas moi
directement en fait tu vois c'est la
notion d'insultes elle a complètement
dans la tête des gens visiblement j'ai
pas donc oui quand on dit un journaliste
qui est malhonnête qu'il est payé ou qui
fait ça par intérêt ou pas sinon les
mecs comprennent pas que c'est une
insulte bah si bah écoute moi je trouve
que c'est pire que tout je préférais
qu'on me dise sale con plutôt que
malhonnête et bon voilà donc les gens
comprennent pas que quand ils insultent
on puisse de temps en temps répondre et
dans la vraie vie on ne rencontre que
des gens bienveillants formidables
l'after une émission qui marche on est
on est on est beaucoup plus aimé que
détesté parce que je pense qu'au bout
d'un moment si tu aimes pas bah
t'écoutes pas tu passes à autre chose
voilà au bout d'un moment à un moment à
l'époque de mon fils direct et eux ils
adorent verratti ils disent que tu es un
con de dire ça et tout déjà j'espère que
c'est un pote à toi dit que tu es un con
tu allais en colline non il faut pas
faire ça pardon mais après ce qui s'est
passé cette saison le match contre le
Bayern et tout finalement tout ses potes
sont allés voir les raisons la Ligue 1
le 5e championnat je c'est les Français
qui dit ça devant son Labrune qui dit ça
mais le cinquième de quoi en fait je
sais pas et c'est lui qui a inventé le
concept c'est du marketing mais si tu
vois en Italie en Espagne cette histoire
de Big Five ils savent parce que ça veut
dire chaque année on coupe d'Europe on
se prend des tartes dans la tronche donc
je vois pas en quoi tu es tu es Big Five
ouais lundi USA pour l'instant t5e en
terme d'oseille t5e mais tu pourrais
très bien être
numéro un du bigfort de France Portugal
Pays-Bas et j'en sais rien Ukraine là ça
arrange Vincent Labrune de dire que tu
es le dernier du Big Five où il y a
Angleterre Espagne Italie - Allemagne
mais tu pourrais très bien être premier
d'un bigfort avec les équipes de
derrière donc voilà tout ça c'est juste
des appellations c'est du marketing tout
ce qu'on voit c'est que chaque année tu
te fais humilier en Coupe d'Europe
contre des équipes en bois je sais pas
les autres travail et nous on rentre sur
le terrain en Europa League en pensant
que c'est facile en pensant que si on
joue des Belges ou des Ukrainiens ou des
Portugais c'est facile justement parce
qu'à force de dire qu'on est dans le Big
Five on pense qu'on appartient au un
groupe de devant je pense que si on
disait qu'on appartient au groupe de
derrière peut-être qu'on aurait un peu
moins de complexe supérieurs et
peut-être qu'on aurait un peu moins le
melon on se la raconterait un petit peu
moins et on aura un peu plus d'humilité
au moment de jouer chaque tard Bruges ou
j'en sais rien qui à chaque fois nous
nous colle des tôles quoi je sais pas
c'est la honte encore ce qui s'est passé
c'est un en Coupe d'Europe c'était
minable je pense qu'il y a un vrai
problème d'approche le football français
est très prétentieux club formateur je
sais pas quand tu regardes les résultats
de l'équipe U20 mondial U20 enfin tu as
perdu contre la Corée et la Gambie quoi
donc excuse-moi tu formes énormément de
joueurs donc comme tu as une quantité
qui est monstrueuse dans cette quantité
tu as des bons et comme c'est bon tu les
envoies des 19 20 ans à l'étranger ils
finissent leur formation qui est la
formation la plus importante qui est
celle dans la tête qui est celle du
sérieux que tu vas mettre au travail à
l'étranger et après l'équipe de France
les récupère plus tard et entière profit
mais au départ la formation elle est pas
si extraordinaire que ça c'est juste que
tu as une matière première qui énorme
parce que tu as un réservoir de joueurs
monstrueux en Île-de-France et c'est
devenu une sorte de Silicon Valley où on
a 1000 jeunes dans dans dans
l'Île-de-France dans les quartiers qui
font du foot et sur cette quantité
arrive à avoir plein de bons joueurs tu
es le premier exportateur de jouer dans
le monde ah mais sauf que quand tu quand
il se barre à 19 20 ans moi j'estime que
en fait c'est un petit peu comme si tu
avais des hectares d'orangers et les
clubs étrangers viennent prendre les
oranges mais c'est eux qui les pressent
et qui les mettent dans dans les
bouteilles c'est eux qui en ont le jus
nous on a juste les oranges quoi mais si
tu sais pas comment bien les presser bah
ton jus ton jus est pas bon nous en fait
après on garde un peu les moins bons qui
jouent dans les clubs de Ligue 1 et ça
donne les résultats en Coupe d'Europe
les étrangers ils prennent les meilleurs
oranges ils font les jus et puis ils
font jouer et moi mais c'est juste parce
que tu as tu as des hectares d'orangers
quoi comme on dit que la formation elle
est bonne mais elle est pas si
extraordinaire que ça contrairement à ce
qu'on dit